[Musique étrangère]
sympathisez avec moi pour nous tous en tant que
famille, vous
voyez, il attend d'être roi depuis
70 ans, je pense qu'il fera du bon travail
ouais la reine était dans sa position
et je pense que pour lui  rester
pertinent, il devra vraiment engager le
public, il le mérite, il a perdu très
longtemps et je suis sûr qu'il sera un très
bon roi,
allez, il y a
trop de gens dans ce pays
qui ont une haute opinion de la famille royale.
les foules qui viennent aujourd'hui et toute cette
semaine et pendant le Jubilé je pense que cela
montre qu'il y a encore euh il y a encore
beaucoup de désir pour la monarchie la
monarchie est incroyablement populaire plus
populaire que jamais mais c'était un effet
de la reine devenant pour ainsi dire  Au-delà de
la critique, je sais que je pense que beaucoup de gens
de ma génération sont moins favorables à la monarchie
que les générations plus âgées, mais
je pense qu'il y a des problèmes plus urgents à
traiter que tout type de
changement gouvernemental en ce moment,
honnêtement, je ne crois pas en la
monarchie, je vois juste  crois qu'ils
vivent des
bénéfices de la piraterie et de l'esclavage je pense que
c'est une bonne chose qu'il y ait une monarchie
tu sais je
ne sais pas peux tu je ne peux pas voir la Grande Bretagne
sans une monarchie d'il y a cinq ans
ayant une conversation avec  amis,
nous avions un fort sentiment, alors ce
pays pourrait être président un jour pour
l'instant, nous nous serions attendus peut-être à ce que ce
soit la fin de la
monarchie vraiment mais honnêtement puisque depuis
la réponse à Charles, je pense que ça va
juste garder  continuez et
rien ne changera vraiment et il sera
vous savez et une autre
figure de proue importante et disons que nous chanterons,
dites n'importe quoi